vous attaquez à des métiers des emplois
des salariés qui ont une difficile au
travail pour 233 contre 99 le Sénat a
adopté l'article premier vous avez donc
décidé de bordéliser de bordéliser un
secteur majeur de notre souveraineté
énergétique la suppression de plusieurs
dans ceux de la RATP de la Tour de
France et des secteurs de l'énergie la
CGT énergie déjà en grève vous le savez
dans les centrales nucléaires nous
savons que ces régimes ont été créés un
moment où ils pouvaient sembler
nécessaire mais qu'aujourd'hui les
différences qu'ils ont par rapport au
régime général ne justifient plus car
c'est pas nous qui votons la réforme de
Monsieur Macron c'est la majorité de
Monsieur Macron qui a choisi de voter
notre réforme il y a quand même une
différence et on va substantiellement
d'ailleurs modifier le texte on fera de
cette réforme une vraie réforme
d'ailleurs de droite voilà qui ne
devrait pas calmer la colère de ceux qui
con se rendre dans la rue mardi
plusieurs professions d'ailleurs
anticipées la grève et commencer à
débrayer mettre la France à l'arrêt
mardi c'est l'objectif affiché par les
syndicats qui multiplient les tractages
devant des centres commerciaux bonne
journée merci bon courage ou sur les
marchés comme ici au Havre je sais que
pour beaucoup ce sera de toute façon une
vraie galère je pense à ceux qui ne
peuvent pas télétravailler qui ont
besoin les transports publics ont besoin
des transports pour se rendre au travail
ou pour rendre visite à leur famille
donc on aura le détail exact communiqué
par la SNCF et la RATP d'ici demain
matin mais je l'ai déjà dit on sait
qu'on sera sur une journée où il y aura
peu de transports publics que j'ai
toujours pensé que reculé pourrait même
Macron ce serait abdiqué sur le plan
symbolique évidemment mais que en
réalité
il reculait il ne pourrait plus réformer
et ce serait terminé de son quinquennat
évidemment qu'à partir du moment où vous
demandez des efforts à des millions de
Français c'est légitime que ces millions
de Français vous disent nous ne
souhaitons pas que cette réforme soit
mise en place notre responsabilité c'est
de dire quoi c'est dire face à ce qu'on
entend de l'expression des Français on
doit expliquer pourquoi cette réforme
encore une fois est absolument vitale
pour les Français
et c'est ça qu'on doit faire mais dans
le même temps vous voyez bien que dans
ces mêmes sondages trois quarts des
Français vous disent on sait que cette
réforme se fera selon les renseignements
jusqu'à un million 400 000 personnes
sont attendues dans les rues mardi un
niveau proche des premières journées de
mobilisation en janvier l'objectif c'est
de mettre l'économie française de genoux
enfin qu'est-ce que ça veut dire moi
j'ai pas envie de mettre l'économie
française à genoux parce que j'ai pas
envie de faire du tort aux Français et
vous pensez que les syndicats veulent
faire du temps en français ah bah là oui
quand tu dis ça ce que fait la CGT
aujourd'hui c'est une forme
d'appropriation mais vous trouvez que
c'est une forme de privatisation des
moyens de production de la communauté
nationale cette inacceptable fait une
espèce d'inflation de part et d'autre
parce que du côté du gouvernement c'est
pas que des maladresses c'est aussi un
certain nombre de bêtises qui sont dites
mais on l'a fait c'est à dire quand il y
a eu un risque très clair sur le fait
que les Français ne puissent plus
déplacer parce qu'il n'était plus en
capacité de faire un plein d'essence
nous avons réquisitionné et donc s'il
faut s'il y a besoin d'en arriver là
parce qu'on aurait des blocages seuls
évidemment qu'on le fera ce qui est dur
pour les Français c'est précisément que
cette inflation elle dure et qu'ils ont
parfois le sentiment de ne pas en voir
le goût il y aura un bout du tunnel il y
aura un bout du tunnel et notre
responsabilité dans l'intervalle c'est
d'accompagner les Français autant que
possible le Salon de l'Agriculture va
ses portes fins ce soir d'une 59e
édition qui aura connu un grand succès
les chiffres définitifs ne sont pas
encore connus mais on sait qu'il y a eu
chaque jour au moins 50 000 visiteurs et
même hier plus de 100000 j'appelle aussi
la distribution à faire un effort sur
ces marges les gros industriels à faire
un effort sur leur marge l'enjeu c'est
quoi c'est tout simple panier ou pas
panier l'enjeu c'est la facture et le
ticket de caisse des Français une
influence jamais vu qui a contraint le
salon à exceptionnellement baisseridos à
16h30 2h en avance l'organisation
envisage à l'avenir la vente de billets
datés pour mieux maîtriser les foules